Hey guys, Pete here. today's game of
thrones season 8 video is going to focus
in on one scene from one of the teasers
that just came out the other day. it's
not the video I was planning on making
today but I saw some chatter about it
and started looking at it and then I
decided to make a video about it this
video will contain a spoilerish discovery
that some people made on Twitter - so if
you're super spoiler adverse as in you
watch promos and trailers but then don't
want to know if people discover things
that might give away some of the story
later from those promos then this video
is not for you
honestly I didn't know that people fit
in that category like there was that
category but I was looking through some
things on reddit today and I realized
that they do actually exist so yeah if
you don't like that kind of stuff this
is definitely that kind of stuff so
there's been a ton of promo material
coming out we're getting really close
it's like 12 days to go there was a new
poster that shows everyone dead more or
less and they're posed in the snow
frozen in the shape of the Iron Throne
that was accompanied by another one of
their teasers like a pure teaser similar
to the one that we saw with John Arya
and Sansa and the crypts this one was
called aftermath and shows the yard in
Winterfell with artifacts tied to all
the major characters left behind it's
really nice looking spot but I don't
imagine this is actual footage that will
be in season 8 like it's just a pure
teaser that's why I called it that and
although it's interesting especially the
night king leaving at the end and all
that I didn't see a point in making a
whole video about it it's symbolic
there's some interesting stuff there but
it doesn't really show anything for sure
that we could say hey this is gonna be
in in the season what does it mean so I
would just say watch it and see what you
think
there's also been a ton of season 8
photos getting printed in different
magazines which are really nice we see
the Winterfell library it looks like
there's going to be a sit-down between
Daenerys and Sansa so I've seen some
people talking about that but the thing
I've been obsessing about all
des is from the together teaser which I
already made a video about the other day
together was the one that starts out
with teary and doing the voiceover he's
talking in the Great Hall of Winterfell
in that official trailer we see this
shot of John and Daenerys which I
mentioned obviously it was a new shot
but she's standing looking at a fire in
a fireplace and he's standing behind her
things look pretty tense and we see what
looks like him leaving and her not even
turning around to watch him go like you
know she looks pretty mad when I first
looked at it I assumed that they were at
Winterfell because we assumed that
everything in these trailers would be
from the first couple of episodes even
though I expect a lot of stuff to happen
in these few episodes I really didn't
expect to see any in the major
characters moving around the map because
as we've seen in some of these photos
they're all going to be preparing to
fight the battle they're gonna know that
the night king and the White Walkers are
coming so they're gonna do what we've
seen them do they're gonna prepare right
so yeah I thought it was at Winterfell
for sure but then I saw this Twitter
post that someone I know retweeted it
was a brightened version of the trailers
that at wild Targaryen posted like it
was brightened up so you could see what
was going on and then better and in the
replies of that post another Twitter
user at 7-7 31 posted a short clip of
the shot from the trailer superimposed
over a picture of Daenerys sitting in
front of the same fireplace in season 7
obviously Daenerys was in Dragonstone in
season 7 and the fireplace is in
Dragonstone and it looks like these
pictures match up pretty well like
exactly more or less there could be some
trickery involved that I don't know
about but it looks pretty convincing to
me so if they are in Dragonstone in this
shot the question is what are they doing
there or when are they there at the very
least it has me stumped for a couple of
reasons so I figured I would make a
video looking at the different
possibilities there's no way really to
say when exactly this falls in the
timeline since there aren't many
visual clues my thing he had been that
all of what we've seen in the trailers
would be prior to the Battle of episode
3 though that makes sense it makes sense
that they would do that because shit
isn't exactly going to be the same after
that happens it's the Battle of
Winterfell it's the big thing that
they've been really playing up right we
know it's in episode 3 and it's a
defining moment things aren't gonna be
the same after it's over people will die
and so on and so forth showing scenes
that fans could figure out we're in
episodes four five or six wouldn't be a
great strategy for HBO because we're
thinking anyone could die in that battle
if we see characters doing anything
after the Battle of Winterfell then that
gives a lot away so keep that in mind
when I go over these options as for why
they could or would go south so the
first explanation for this shot of them
Dragonstone is that this is after
episode 3 the Battle of Winterfell is
over and they both survived Jon and
Daenerys both survived the battle that
could happen is if they they fought and
they defeated the night king and then
they stopped at Dragonstone before going
to King's Landing if the battle has
happened they won they lived then this
isn't an outrageous idea Dragonstone is
close to King's Landing so that there's
not outrageous that they would stop
there if they're moving south after
their victory the other way that could
go down is the night king destroyed
Winterfell and they retreated there that
could work but if the night king was
chasing the survivors like whoever was
left over after they overran Winterfell
with Jon and Daenerys just peace out and
fly their dragons down to Dragonstone
and wait for everyone to arrive I mean
that seems a little bit strange so both
of these are iffy I I don't think that
everyone is going to survive the Battle
of Winterfell I'm not sure how that's
going to turn out I mean I go kind of
back and forth sometimes I think that
they're gonna kill the night king there
and it's all gonna be done and
times I'm not sure but either way these
is that those are the two post-battle of
winterfell kind of ideas neither one's
perfect but you could kind of make them
work if you had to another idea is one I
don't like that much but it's worth
mentioning because if I don't then
someone will tell me in the comments
that they think it's that so Daenerys
could find out about the night king
raising Viserion she might see this as a
real threat to her dragons that are
still alive and she may decide to leave
for that reason I don't think it's
likely because nothing I mean she's
already lost Viserion when she went
north the last time and she's still
going to Winterfell to fight the dead
like she's not really thinking about it
and in terms of like well maybe this is
a good idea or a bad idea it's an
imperative you know like we have to save
everyone from this threat it just
doesn't seem to me that she would be
like oh well that's a little bit too
risky now that he has a dragon - you
know what I mean it's just nothing has
really come along in the series so far
to make me say that that's what she
would do essentially though if you think
that this is possible then that could be
the explanation is that this is in the
first three episodes it's before the
Battle of Winterfell and they just
essentially went there if that's the
case though then why would Jon accompany
her there like if she was just gonna
leave why would Jon accompany her in
that scenario when he'd be like alright
we'll see you because because we know
his main priority is certainly to fight
the dead I guess you could take it one
step further and say that she left and
then he decided to go and ask her one
more time he followed after the fact or
something but yeah I just don't think
that's as like and the other one is the
thing that I was talking about in my
Daenerys problems video I made a few
days ago in that scenario Jon learns
that Daenerys is pregnant with his child
and he forbids her to fight in the
battle there is some visual evidence for
this all of the stuff that we've seen in
the trailer so far at least stuff with
Jon in it is
John fighting on the ground for at least
part of the Battle of Winterfell John is
is going to be fighting on the ground
with his sword like he's out there doing
hand-to-hand combat we don't see any
dragons in the trailers at all of course
this doesn't really mean much they could
be holding back I mean we barely see the
whites in the videos so far we only see
the one indication of one white Walker
so we don't really know how the battle
is gonna escalate we just know that what
we've seen so far there seems to be some
fire in the background although I think
that there's gonna be bonfires and stuff
to go along with the dragonglass traps
but if John did say that he wanted to
nurse out of there senator Dragonstone
or she'd be safe then that could be why
we don't see that in the trailers we
don't see any dragons really fighting in
the trailer so far to me that seems like
something that he would do I mean that's
what I said the other day when I made
that video I don't foresee him telling
her to go out and fight I I expect that
she would want to I don't think that
that would really sideline her
necessarily I think that's a pretty
plausible storyline I used the word
forbid for that reason like he basically
tells her she can't fight of course this
is not perfect either
because we don't know how fast the night
king and the White Walkers are
descending on Winterfell like would they
have time to just be hanging out and
Dragonstone on having a conversation
that looks heated like this and you know
the stuff I said about Rago
like he would have to fly ragel to
Dragonstone that's the only way he could
get there and back to the battle at
Winterfell in time like we know he's at
the Battle of Winterfell so he'd have to
be in both places which I imagine that
they would tell us he rode the dragon
that's how he was able to get back and
forth but then like if he's doing that
if he's flying regel north to south and
everything else what you gonna do put
Ragle in a pen and you know what I mean
like he's not gonna fight with like he
doesn't it doesn't work out exactly so
yeah it's it's it's interesting and it's
problematic at the same time in
conclusion I think it definitely looks
like they're in Dragonstone
I think logically it makes sense that if
they go there
like if HBO shows us a scene that's
there that the scene has to be before
the third episode it could be a slip-up
but they're pretty in tune with how
seriously people break things down at
this point you know I mean like it
wouldn't be surprising to them that
people would figure this out that this
is where this is that there has just
look at the photos there's plenty of
other things they could have shown
rather than like grabbing a you know one
second clip from episode five or episode
four or something like that so to me it
seems more likely that it's before the
Battle of Winterfell rather than after
and then if it is that then it seems
more likely to me that Jon would be
saying hey you can't fight because
you're with child
rather than Danny saying that she
doesn't want to do it anymore she
changed her mind and that is where I
will leave it loves to hear what you
guys think about this I don't know if
there's any other major explanations for
it I mean I couldn't think of any that
were obvious
I saw one right at some of the people
saying it might be a flashback or it
might be something like that I doubt
it's that but I'm interested to hear
what you guys think so let me know in
the comments if you liked the video
please give it a like
I will pick up the problem series again
soon after this I'm not sure maybe the
day after tomorrow I'll be trying to get
out another video in that series if
anything else interesting comes out
between now and then I'll be sure to
make a video about that thanks for
watching I will talk to you soon